buenas tardes valentín así es como
indica que estamos en corferias que está
situado en bogotá y es el principal
punto del país de votación y el fallo
principal que nos hemos encontrado que
se ha reportado es que la registraduría
que es el órgano principal de dirigir de
organizar estas elecciones ha tenido
caída la página web y han tenido que
hacer un plan de emergencia eso es
importante porque en esta página web es
donde los votantes pueden revisar su
mesa de votación también de la misión de
observación electoral nos llega que
actores armados estarían interrumpiendo
estas elecciones por ejemplo en el meta
en la sierra de la macarena habrían
vuelto muerto un soldado y también que
en seis municipios donde se están
celebrando las votaciones de los curules
de paz nos están entregando tarjetones
además ha habido fallos un señor nos
comentaba antes aquí en las urnas que se
había registrado hacía unos días y que
sin embargo no ha aparecido en las
listas de votaciones fallos menores que
son habituales en este tipo de
elecciones valentina
louis en qué momento se esperan los
primeros resultados tanto del congreso
como de las consultas interpartidistas
esto es importante porque se esperan los
primeros resultados a las 6 de la tarde
y serían de las consultas
interpartidistas después más tarde a lo
largo de la tarde es cuando se van a
conocer cómo queda compuesto el congreso
tanto en el senado como en la cámara de
representantes es importante centrarse
en las consultas interpartidistas porque
están siendo vistas como la primera de
tres vueltas ya que están teniendo una
especial atención ya que saldrán los
candidatos principales de la izquierda
del pacto histórico donde el favorito es
gustavo petro del centro con la
coalición de la esperanza donde el
favorito es sergio fajardo y de la
derecha de equipo por colombia donde el
favorito es federico gutiérrez todo
dependerá de la participación ya que los
analistas consideran que si sube la lo
normal que es un 50 por ciento de
participación un 50 por ciento de
atención si se consigue subir a un 55
por ciento estaríamos hablando de que
nuevas fuerzas y nuevos congresistas
podrían entrar en el congreso de
colombia